>> Greg: PRESIDENT TRUMP SCORE
IS NICE BUT IS TOO MODEST TO RUB
IT IN YOUR FACE.
MORE BRIGHT A LOT.
FINISHED ALL IN ONE STROKE AND
CONTROLLED THE MEDIA WITH A
JOKE.
HAD TRUMP YELLING "FOUR MORE
YEARS?"
[LAUGHTER]
PRESIDENT TRUMP SHUT ALL-IN-ONE
ALLEGEDLY, HE STAYED QUIET AND
DEFENDED ITSELF -- KIDDING.
HE ISSUED A FORMAL STATEMENT.
SMOKE SIGNAL AND CARRIER PIGEON
"MANY PEOPLE ARE ASKING, SO I
WILL GIVE IT TO YOU NOW.
SALES BACK OF A STRONG WIND."
HE'S A BETTER WRITER THAN
HEMINGWAY.
HE ADDED THAT HIS SHOP WAS
BETTER THAN THE GOLF POSE HE WAS
PLAYING WITH, BUT -- HE WAS TOO
HUMBLE."
"I AM A MODEST INDIVIDUAL, AND
YOU WILL SAY I WAS BRAGGING, AND
I DON'T LIKE PEOPLE WHO BRAG."
THAT'S A HUMBLE BRAG.
THE LAPTOP IS A REAL COMMAND
POLLS SHOWING THAT HE WOULD BE
HANDLING IT, THE REMATCH ALONG
WITH THIS HOLE-IN-ONE.
IT'S A GOOD TIME TO BE
DONALD TRUMP.
SOURCES SAY ADAM SCHIFF PLANS TO
FORM A COMMITTEE TO INVESTIGATE
THE SHOT, WHICH IS SEEN AND HAS
CALLED RACIST AND A THREAT TO
DEMOCRACY AS WE KNOW IT.
I SHOULD GO TO A FAMILY MEMBER
FIRST.
TYRUS?
GETTING.
ERIC.
HE'S A GOOD WRITER.
HE CAN WRITE SOMETHING THAT CAN
MAKE PEOPLE UNDERSTAND HIM
LAUGH, AND THE PEOPLE THAT DON'T
ANGRY.
>> THAT'S THE GREATEST TROLL.
[LAUGHTER]
>> HE'S CLEARLY LAUGHING WHEN HE
IS WRITING THIS.
>> SPEAKS TO WHO HE IS.
WE STAB A CHEERLEADER IN THIS
COUNTRY FOR THE UNITED STATES,
FOR OUR ECONOMY, FOR COMPANIES,
LAW ENFORCEMENT, MILITARY, VETS,
EVERYTHING WE LOVED ABOUT THE
U.S.
DELOS WAS NEVER ONE TO
DONALD TRUMP COMMAND PRACTICALLY
EVERYTHING WE DID.
IN A STATEMENT LIKE THAT WHERE
HE IS CHEERLEADING SOMETHING,
THAT'S INGRAINED IN HIS DNA.
IT SIGNIFIES SOMETHING MORE.
WE NEED SOMEBODY TO CHEERLEAD
FOR OUR NATION AGAIN.
I'M SICK AND TIRED OF THAT.
>> AND HERE FOR YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
TYRUS, DO YOU EVER GOLF?
>> I GOLF WITH MY KIDS, BECAUSE
I LIKE GOING YARD.
HIT IT OUT OF THE PARK, GREG.
THAT'S A BASEBALL TURN.
[LAUGHTER]
I HAVE A HOME RUN IN COLLEGE.
>> IT'S LIFE-CHANGING.
IT'S NOT EASY.
HOLE-IN-ONE, SOMEONE TELLS YOU
YOU WERE GOING ALSO SO SLOW,
SUDDENLY, WANTS TO DO EVERYTHING
YOU DO WHEN THEY LOOK AT YOUR
CAR AND IT'S LIKE -- BUY ME A
BEER."
IT'S A GREAT MOMENT.
CONSIDERING THE DAMAGE HE DID AT
THE ACADEMY AWARDS --
HE DID CAUSE VIOLENCE PAIRED >>
THAT'S TRUE, HE NORMALIZED
VIOLENCE.
ONE THING WE KNOW ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP AS HE IS GOOD
FOR A BACKHAND.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY TIMES WE
SAW HIM PUTTING HANDS ON
SOMEBODY IN THE OFFICE.
[LAUGHTER]
LET HIM HAVE THE HOLE-IN-ONE FOR
A MOMENT.
I CAN SEE YOU THERE IS BLOGS
COMING, THE RACIST GRAPH.
[LAUGHTER]
>> NORMALIZING ALL-IN-ONE.
I HAVE A GUY WHO DOES NINE HOLES
IN ONE.
HIS NAME IS BOZO.
[LAUGHTER]
IF YOU PLAY EVERY DAY, EVERY
WORD IF YOU DIDN'T HAVE ONE.
>> NOTHING WITH TIM JONES ON 9-1
ROUND.
>> IF YOU RECALL.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I'VE NEVER HAD A LONG RUN.
I'VE PLAYED A LOT OF MINIGOLF.
I HAD HOLE-IN-ONE'S THERE THAT I
AM PROUD OF.
[LAUGHTER]
>> YOU COULD DRAPE YOURSELF IN
AN AMERICAN FLAG.
[LAUGHTER]
"USA" TRAMPEDS ALL OVER THE
COURT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> HE SAID A RATHER STRONG WIND
BOUNCED TWICE, WENT INTO THE
HOLE.
>> IT'S BETTER -- WHAT YOU SAID
IS SO RIGHT!
>> HE WRITES IT BECAUSE THE
PEOPLE WHO LOVE HIM ENJOY IT,
AND THE PEOPLE WHO HATE HIM
CAN'T STAND IT.
>> I BET YOU WOULD BE CONFLICTED
AT A GOLF COURSE WHEN YOU GET TO
THE WINDMILL, BECAUSE HE WOULD
BE LIKE "I'M NOT FOR WIND
POWER."
HOW WOULD YOU PLAY?
[LAUGHTER]
>> I WOULD BOYCOTT THAT.
WALK AROUND THE HOLE.
>> HAVE YOU EVER TOUCHED A GOLF
CLUB?
>> I HAVE ENGULFED IN A WHILE.
>> WAS IT A DATE?
>> IT WAS MY UNCLE AND MY
BROTHER.
I DIDN'T MAKE ANY OF THE HOLES.
[LAUGHTER]
NO MATTER HOW HARD I TRIED.
I CRIED SO HARD AFTERNOON, AND I
THOUGHT "I CAN NEVER HAVE A JOB
THAT REQUIRES ME TO GO GOLFING
WITH MY COLLEAGUES."
I DON'T THINK I COULD BEHAVE
DIFFERENTLY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> YOU CAME FAR DESPITE NOT
BEING ABLE TO GOLF.
>> A REGULAR SPALDING.
[LAUGHTER]
>> IT'S OKAY, ALL RIGHT.
>> TECHNOLOGY